en 1963 tu épouses en train suzy après
toutes ces années de ça faisait
longtemps que vous connaissiez quand
même et tu empruntes pas de quoi de
payer un taxi tu vas en prendre là la
camionnette d'un ami maçon et un costume
bleu marine qui était couvert de plaques
quand j'ai vu dans télé 7 jours le
mariage de ta fille je suis à la
différence la wii ce que je veux
expliquer c'est que toute ma vie moi
j'ai élevé mes enfants ou pas j'espère
que enfin ils le reconnaissent fait pas
comme des enfants de riches ou des
enfants deux des fils à papa des enfants
est par contre j'ai toujours désiré
qu'il n'ait pas les mêmes problèmes que
moi quand j'étais jeune et j'ai souhaité
que pour le mariage de mes enfants
il est l'abondance que j'ai pas pu avoir
pour moi alors à cette époque là tu
galères un peu parce que tu trouve pas
de travail dans l'enseignement
c'est un peu difficile quand 63 par là
et tu te faut engager dans un cabaret à
30 bal par jour ce qui était ce qui
était pas beaucoup et là il ya quelque
chose d'assez touchant c'est quand des
pieds noirs étaient là et qu'il invitait
à leur table tu prenais la consommation
la moins chère parce que tu savais qu'il
n'avait pas beaucoup d'argent et le
patron faisait la gueule non
ça c'est vrai nom mais c'est ça me
rappelle une histoire véridique il
m'était arrivé dans un cabaret à la
table ronde
je j'arrive à sept heures du soir comme
d'habitude et à quelqu'un qui m'invite à
la table mais il n'y avait personne
n'avait que lui alors il je pose ma
guitare et puis me dis qu'est-ce que
vous prenez jeudi un petit café et lors
le le patron du cabaret m'appelle et me
dit c'est comme ça que tu fais marcher
les affaires de la maison au lieu de
demander du champagne pour missing glace
à dieu et dieu merci il ya du lendemain
les rails et mme tout le monde
et voilà que ils m'en veulent et il me
fit d'une claque alors moi je réplique
je donne un coup de poing
sa femme elle arrive derrière avec un
balai elle me donne un coup de balai sur
la tête
bon moi je récupère ma guitare parce que
je pensais que ma guitare et je sors est
évident que j'ai perdu la place voit un
quand tu chantes des fois mon pays
les métropolitains sont assez agressif
avec toi cette époque là ils disent
d'abord c'est pas ton pays et puis tu
feras plus jamais suer le burnous sans
faille avait quand même une agressivité
très très difficile
alors moi je mettais toujours adieu mon
pays vu mon expérience et à ce sujet là
je la mettais toujours à la fin à la fin
de mon spectacle parce que je savais que
derrière je pouvais plus rire chanter
pas ça se finisse est en bagarre
générale
mais des fois tu es obligé de quitter la
scène où ils sachent s'en plaint j'ai
quitté mon pays
les retourne dans ton pays et frisés
ceci cela alors il y en avait qui
premier mais pas moi j'avais pas besoin
de moi je descendais furtivement dans ma
loge je savais que c'était la fin du
spectacle c'était la bagarre générale
alors un jour il ya un miracle dans ta
vie c'est igor barrère qui fait un cinq
colonnes à la une il veut une séquence
sur les pieds noirs et il te demande de
jouer au milieu de nous il manque
d'illustration sonore c'est incroyable
et on me fait une à la mutualité ont
fini
le film et ça devait passer le vendredi
d'après donc une semaine après et igor
barrère viens boire un coup avec moi au
bar en face de la mutualité je m'en
rappellerai comme si c'était hier
et me dit voilà enrico tout va bien la
séquence s'est très bien passé mais
c'est la séquence qui sautent s'y est
jamais un événement important se passe
dans la semaine alors tous les jours je
lisais le journal pour savoir pourvu que
ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui meurt pourvu
qu'ils aient pas associé du national
pour que la séquence mal et je me
rappelle à huit heures du soir ce avant
même le générique c'est ma tête qu'on
voit à la télévision française à cinq
colonnes à la une et avec toute la
famille réunie ma grand mère mon
grand-père toute la famille mon père ma
mère mes enfants n'étaient pas nés
évidemment encore c'était aussi là c'est
le succès parce que c'est immédiat il ya
des gens c'est immédiat parce que
j'avais pris le métro avant d'aller chez
chez ma tante rue lepic plus on voir
l'émission et quand l'émission était
passée en direct à 8h30 j'ai repris de
métro pour aller ailleurs et
je ne pouvais plus faire un pas dans la
rue et mon père étaient qui était avec
moi m'a dit ça y est mon fils tu es une
version bien